Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 81. Ausgabe hier in unserer Gesprächsreihe über Wissenschaft, wissenschaftliche Fragen
und alles was damit zusammenhängt.
Ja und wie das jetzt so der neue Stil ist, wird auch diese Sendung natürlich aus der Ferne aufgenommen.
Und das passt auch ganz gut, denn wir wollen über Wissenschaftskommunikation reden.
Und da kommen ja ein paar neue Aufgaben gerade hinzu, so hat es den Eindruck.
Das wollen wir alles klären und besprechen.
Ich begrüße Frau Stefanie Molthagen-Schnöring, hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Frau Molthagen-Schnöring, Sie sind, ja, alles mögliche.
Sie beschreiben sich selber auch als Kommunikatorin, würde ich mal sagen, aber auch als Moderatorin.
Da steckt eine ganze Menge drin, aber vor allem haben Sie es ja auch studiert, Kommunikationswissenschaften und Kulturwissenschaften unter anderem, richtig?
Richtig, genau.
Immer schon an Schnittstellen aktiv gewesen, vielfältig interessiert und schnell für viele Themen zu begeistern.
Das Ganze war dann, glaube ich, gepaart noch mit einem Germanistikstudium, was kam denn hier zuerst oder war das alles gleichzeitig?
In der Tat war eigentlich mein ursprünglicher Berufswunsch immer, etwas mit Sprache zu machen und Germanistik war irgendwie das naheliegendste,
wenn man im Deutschunterricht sich so vorstellte, man möchte auch weiterhin gerne schreiben und sprechen.
Und da hatte ich damals als erstes eben diesen Impuls, Germanistik zu studieren, auch durchaus wegen der Literaturwissenschaft.
Habe dann aber sehr schnell gemerkt, dass mir eigentlich die Linguistik, also die Sprachwissenschaft, sehr viel mehr Freude bringt
und sich auch viel besser vereinen lässt mit den Interessen, sowohl im wissenschaftlichen also auch im praktischen Bereich,
weil man wunderbar analysieren kann, wie Sprache sich entwickelt, was passiert, wenn Menschen miteinander sprechen.
Und insofern habe ich Germanistik mit dem Schwerpunkt Linguistik studiert und die anderen Fächer waren wie Nebenfächer.
Was passiert denn, wenn Menschen miteinander sprechen?
Ja, ganz interessante Dinge passieren da natürlich.
Also verschiedenste Ebenen werden angesprochen, sowohl rational als auch emotional.
Wir kennen ja alle diese einfachen, aber dennoch richtigen, Kommunikationsmodelle von Watzlawick und Schulz von Thun und anderen,
nach denen man eben bei der Kommunikation merkt, dass wir eben nicht nur auf einer rein inhaltlichen Ebene miteinander sprechen,
sondern auch eine Beziehungsebene und andere Ebenen da mit im Spiel sind und das Ganze natürlich dann noch geframt wird von den verschiedenen Rahmenbedingungen,
wenn wir uns in einem Unternehmen befinden oder in der Wissenschaft befinden oder in der Politik befinden,
so dass Kommunikation am Ende doch ganz schön komplex ist.
Da werden wir gleich weiter noch drauf eingehen.
Jetzt würde mich aber nochmal kurz Ihr weiterer Lebensweg an der Stelle interessieren, weil es ist ja beim Studium nicht geblieben.
Sie haben dann aber auch keine rein wissenschaftliche Karriere eingeschlagen mit den drei Studien im Gepäck.
Genau, ich wollte eigentlich nach dem Studium erst mal raus und ein bisschen stärker in der Praxis tätig werden
und bin von daher direkt nach meiner Promotion in einer Kommunikationsberatung gelandet
und habe dort zunächst einmal mich mit Geschäftsberichten beschäftigt, auch eine sehr spezielle Form der Kommunikation.
Durfte also für große Konzerne Geschäftsberichte mit konzipieren und dann kamen irgendwann Nachhaltigkeitsberichte dazu.
Dann kam die strategische Kommunikation dazu.
Und dann kam irgendwann die Liebe dazu und der Liebe wegen bin ich dann aus Hamburg damals nach Berlin gezogen
und habe dort in einer Kommunikationsagentur gearbeitet, die sehr viel für Ministerien tätig war,
auch eben schon im Bereich der Wissenschaft, für das BMBF, aber auch andere
und durfte dann dort als Leitung Strategiekampagnen und Kommunikationsaktivitäten mit entwickeln für diese Kunden.
Also unter anderem für Ministerien, nicht nur für Ministerien?
Genau, unter anderem auch weiterhin für Unternehmen, von daher für NGOs, also ein breites Spektrum.
Auch für politische Parteien, so dass man in der Tat mal einen Blick in diese verschiedenen Systeme werfen konnte.
Die Wissenschaft dann auch oder bezog sich das erst mal noch nicht unbedingt darauf?
Wir haben damals auch für Hochschulen Kommunikation gemacht.
Also es gibt ja auch Hochschulen, die beispielsweise Image-Broschüren oder Geschäftsberichte rausbringen,
aber eben nicht für einzelne Forschungsaktivitäten oder wenn dann für Forschungsaktivitäten, dann eben eher von der Seite der Ministerien.
Allerdings, muss ich sagen, hat mich die Wissenschaft nie losgelassen und ich habe in meiner Zeit bei den Agenturen dann doch manchmal vermisst,
dass man sich wieder ein bisschen intellektueller mit Themen beschäftigt und habe von daher auch während ich in den Agenturen war den Kontakt gehalten,
war Lehrbeauftragte, weil ich auch das vermisst habe eben Wissen zu vermitteln.
Habe dann an verschiedenen Hochschulen in Berlin und auch außerhalb von Berlin eben Lehraufträge gehabt.
Und so kam dann immer mehr der Wunsch wieder zurückzukommen in die Wissenschaft.
Und das ist Ihnen ja dann auch ganz gut gelungen, denn mittlerweile sind Sie Professorin für Wirtschaftskommunikation an der Hochschule für Technik und Wissenschaft in Berlin.
Hochschule für Technik und Wirtschaft, genau, das ist die…
Okay, ja das wird heute, glaube ich, noch fünfmal durcheinander geraten.
Das ist okay, das passiert mir auch manchmal, Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft sind nah beieinander.
Ja.
Genau, seit 2011 bin ich dort Professorin für Wirtschaftskommunikation mit dem Schwerpunkt Text und Medien.
Das heißt, ich bin wieder auch durchaus an meine linguistischen Wurzeln zurückgekehrt
und erarbeite eben auch mit Studierenden, was sind eigentlich Kriterien für gute Texte, aber natürlich beschränkt sich die Kommunikation nicht auf textliche Kommunikation,
sondern dann kommt die visuelle Kommunikation dazu, die persönliche Kommunikation, insofern ist das ein breites Spektrum.
Ich lehre viel im Bereich Kommunikationsmanagement mit einem starken Fokus schon auch auf Öffentlichkeitsarbeit von Institutionen jeder Art.
Und aufgrund meiner Interessen und auch Erfahrungen in meinem vorherigen Berufsleben geht das auch stark in Richtung Kommunikation eben von NGOs,
von politischen Institutionen und eben auch vermehrt von der Wissenschaft.
Jetzt ist ja die HTW ohnehin so ein bunter Fleck in der Universitätslandschaft in Berlin, die ja vor allem so durch die großen Universitäten so dominiert ist.
Ich habe aber immer so den Eindruck, dass die HTW so auch mit ihrem Fokus auf angewandte Wissenschaften so eine Sonderstellung einnimmt
und auch ein bisschen anders kommuniziert, anders sich nach außen gibt als es die anderen Universitäten tun.
Ist das ein berechtigter Eindruck?
Also wenn Sie das positiv wahrnehmen, freut mich das und das ist natürlich total berechtigt.
In der Tat finde ich, dass wir eine sehr gute offensive Kommunikation machen, sicherlich auch an der Stelle sich bemerkbar macht,
dass wir eben nicht nur eine technische Hochschule sind, sondern auch Kreativ- und Kulturstudiengänge bei uns haben,
so dass die Kommunikation eben auch teilweise mit entwickelt wurde von den entsprechenden Kolleginnen, also auch die Außenkommunikation
und auch Studierende bei uns sehr aktiv sind, die Projekte machen, um eben beispielsweise mal zu lernen, wie macht man denn eine Webseite
oder ein Magazin oder eine Kampagne und das spiegelt sich auch in unserer Kommunikation wieder.
Und in der Tat ist es das, was ich eigentlich so faszinierend an dieser Hochschule finde, dass wir, wenn ich dieses ja doch sehr strapazierte Wort gebrauchen darf,
interdisziplinäre, transdisziplinär aufgestellt sind.
Ich bin jetzt seit einem Jahr Vizepräsidentin für Forschung und Transfer in der Hochschule und lerne immer mehr die verschiedenen Studiengänge,
wir haben um die 70 Studiengänge, kennen und merke, wie spannend das ist,
wenn jetzt eben beispielsweise die regenerativen Energien gemeinsame Projekte mit den Kommunikationsdesignern machen
oder wenn es Projekte gibt zwischen BWL und Informatik, also da gibt es ganz viele gemeinsame Themen,
die ja heute quasi auf der Hand liegen, wenn man sich anschaut, was wir für große Herausforderungen in unserer Gesellschaft haben.
Digitalisierung, Klimawandel etc., die glaube ich keine Disziplin allein wird lösen können.
Und da sehe ich einfach das große Potential der Hochschule und das macht mir persönlich auch wahnsinnig viel Spaß
und da sind wir wieder beim Thema Schnittstellen und Grenzgänger.
Wir hatten ja auch schon Ihren Kollegen Volker Quaschning hier im Gespräch, der ja auch ziemliche Sichtbarkeit sich selbst erarbeitet hat,
insbesondere in der Klimawandeldiskussion in der letzten Zeit auch nochmal besonders erhalten hat.
Auch wenn das natürlich jetzt gerade in der Corona-Krise alles so ein bisschen auf Platz 2 geschoben zu werden scheint.
Aber diese Freiräume zu bieten oder auch zu lassen vielmehr, ist das eine bewusste Politik an der HTW?
Ja, das durchaus, also es ist uns sehr wichtig, im Rahmen unserer Transferstrategie, dass wir eben eine größtmögliche Öffnung gegenüber Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft herstellen können
und das ist natürlich sehr vielfältig aufgrund der verschiedensten Profile, die Professorinnen und Mitarbeiterinnen bei uns haben,
und auch nicht jeder möchte mit Wissenschaftskommunikation nach außen treten, sondern es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten natürlich des Transfers.
Es gibt Kollegen, die setzen sich dafür ein, dass Studierende, die ein Unternehmen gründen wollen, beispielsweise mit ihren Gründungsideen weiter vorankommen.
Es gibt Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die sind sehr aktiv im Bereich von Schule, dass sie beispielsweise auch Angebote für Schülerinnen machen.
So dass, glaube ich, da eine große Freiheit da ist, sich ja auch ein bisschen auszuleben und seinen Interessen zu folgen.
Mich freut es natürlich jetzt persönlich sehr, dass wir mit Volker Quaschning jemanden haben, der sehr präsent ist in diesem ganzen Klimadiskurs
und dass natürlich auch in irgendeiner Form dann auf die HTW wieder abstrahlt, insofern ist das jetzt auch eine win-win-Situation, wenn man so will,
aber auch etwas, was man wie gesagt jetzt nicht von jedem erwarten kann.
Wir hatten ja das Thema Wissenschaftskommunikation hier schon aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln betrachtet.
Mit Onur Güntürkün haben wir hier schon mal länger drüber gesprochen, aber auch so Nebenaspekte, so wie Science Slams,
also mehr so kulturelle Aktivitäten, um sozusagen Wissenschaft ins Volk zu bringen.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Ziele, die man haben kann.
So auf der einen Seite so ein bisschen eben die Ansprache der Öffentlichkeit, des Mainstreams, sozusagen die Akzeptanz von Wissenschaft als solche zu fördern,
so als höheres Ziel, aber natürlich auch genauso eben die konkrete Vermittlung zum eigenen Forschungsnutzen, sich selbst bekannt zu machen, Forschung bekannt zu machen,
natürlich auch im weiteren Sinne Drittmittel anzuwerben, all diese ganzen Zwänge, das ist ja bekannt.
Gerade diese Perspektive, die Sie jetzt haben, interessant mich jetzt erst mal zwischen Wissenschafts- und Wirtschaftskommunikation.
Gibt es denn da jetzt erst mal einen grundlegenden Unterschied in der Herangehensweise, wie hier Wissenschaft oder Wirtschaft an eine Öffentlichkeit herangehen sollten
oder sehen Sie da erst mal beide Bereiche gleich aufgestellt?
Also ich glaube, in den Methoden und in den Prozessen gibt es keine großen Unterschiede.
Also wenn ich als Unternehmen kommunizieren will, muss ich mir genauso darüber Gedanken machen, wer sind eigentlich meine Zielgruppen,
als wenn ich das Ganze als Hochschule oder als Wissenschaftler tue.
Das heißt, so bestimmte Fragestellungen Richtung Ziele, Richtung Zielgruppen, was sind die Botschaften, mit denen ich nach außen treten möchte
und mit welchen Maßnahmen möchte ich dann eben mein Publica überzeugen, das sind im Prinzip ja mehr oder weniger universelle Standards.
Das ist sicherlich, wenn man mit viel Geld hantieren kann, hat man da vielleicht andere Möglichkeiten, aber auf der anderen Seite glaube ich,
ist alleine so das im Kopf zu haben, dass es eben diese verschiedenen Fragestellungen gibt, auch für Wissenschaftler unglaublich hilfreich,
weil sie dann nämlich plötzlich erkennen, ah okay, ich muss jetzt auch nicht immer die Öffentlichkeit überzeugen,
sondern ich habe vielleicht jetzt gerade, wie Sie schon selber sagten, vielleicht eher ein bestimmtes Lobbying-Interesse.
Ich möchte vielleicht an bestimmte Unternehmen ran, mit denn ich gemeinsam Projekte machen möchte.
Also dass man sozusagen sich da auch entscheiden muss, mit wem möchte ich eigentlich kommunizieren?
Abgesehen davon, da haben Sie natürlich völlig recht, dass die Wissenschaft schon auch nochmal in einer anderen Verantwortung ist,
erst recht, wenn sie stabil finanziert ist.
Und ich glaube, die Verantwortung, die wir als Wissenschaft jetzt heute haben in diesen Zeiten, auch in Bezug auf die Förderung eines demokratischen Diskurses,
das sehe ich als eine Aufgabe, die jetzt doch nochmal stärker bei der Wissenschaft als bei der Wirtschaft liegt,
auch wenn sich die Wirtschaft in den letzten Monaten und Jahren ja auch zunehmend zu gesellschaftspolitischen Fragestellungen geäußert hat.
Oder äußern muss.
Oder äußern muss, absolut genau.
Aber natürlich auch mit einem spezifischen eigenen Interesse.
Und ich glaube, auch die Wissenschaft und auch Wissenschaftlerinnen haben eben ein Eigeninteresse,
also es ist nicht nur immer zum Wohle des Ganzen sozusagen, sondern man möchte, wie wir gerade schon besprochen hatten,
da eben auch bestimmte Ziele erreichen.
Insofern merken Sie, die riesigen Unterschiede sehe ich jetzt vielleicht nicht.
Abgesehen davon, dass natürlich die Art der Finanzierung und schon auch die Eigeninteressen von Wirtschaft schon nochmal deutlicher zutage treten
als es in der Wissenschaft vielleicht der Fall ist.
Und ich glaube, da kann man auch durchaus noch Aufklärung leisten für die Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Ich meine, diese Zielgruppen auszumachen, ist es überhaupt …
Also inwiefern ist es denn sinnvoll, diese Zielgruppen überhaupt zu unterscheiden?
Denn ich habe so ein bisschen so auch den Eindruck, dass man sich heutzutage das auch gar nicht mehr so genau aussuchen kann.
Klassische non-online, nicht digitale Kommunikation war ja immer sehr zielgerichtet, einfach zwangsläufig durch die Limitierung des Weges.
Wem schicke ich die Briefe, wer nimmt an einer Konferenz teil?
Also diese Öffentlichkeiten, die man vorher bereitstellen konnten, waren ja in sich schon mal sehr klar geordnet.
Aber wenn man heutzutage über Social Media oder eben auch nur über seine Webseite kommuniziert, kann man sich ja im Prinzip jeden einfangen
und viele stellen dann eben auch fest, man fängt sich dann eben auch mehr ein, andere ein als man gedacht hat und stellt dann halt auf einmal fest,
so oha, da passt aber jetzt meine Sprache gar nicht, denn ich werde jetzt hier komplett falsch verstanden,
andererseits, oh Gott, was mache ich denn jetzt, ich habe ja gar keine andere Sprache bzw. denkt man oder vielleicht ist es dann auch so, jetzt ist meine Sprache gar nicht geeignet,
überhaupt alle nur in irgendeiner Form erdenklichen Öffentlichkeiten anzusprechen.
Also wie würden Sie denn sozusagen generell Zielgruppen unterscheiden oder macht so eine Unterscheidung gar keinen Sinn?
Also ich glaube, generell kann man das nicht unterscheiden.
Man muss halt eben darüber klar nachdenken, in welchem Feld bewege ich mich und was will ich eben erreichen?
Und natürlich, wenn ich in den sozialen Medien unterwegs bin, dann habe ich ein stärkeres Grundrauschen immer dabei
und habe natürlich auch eine andere Öffentlichkeit, als wenn ich in spezifische Fachöffentlichkeiten gehe.
Aber auch das kann ich natürlich über soziale Medien machen, wenn ich in bestimmte Fachgruppen reingehe,
die es ja auch auf sozialen Medien gibt und mich dort dann öfter zu Wort melde.
Insofern ist es immer noch eine Entscheidung, welches Ziel will ich mit meiner Kommunikation erreichen?
Möchte ich mich als Wissenschaftler profilieren und eine Marke aufbauen, dann ist es vielleicht für mich wichtig,
dass ich in Twitter oder anderen sozialen Medien auch unterwegs bin.
Möchte ich mit Journalistinnen ins Gespräch kommen oder sage ich, nein das ist alles irgendwie nicht meins, aber ich habe ein hohes Interesse daran,
in meinem spezifischen Forschungsfeld diese Reputation zu haben, dann werde ich eben andere Medien bedienen und andere Wege gehen.
Und auch das ist natürlich trotzdem immer noch auch Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Insofern wir müssen uns diese Frage immer stellen, wen wollen wir von etwas überzeugen?
Wenn ich jetzt einfach nur Kommunikation in den Raum hinein mache und mich dann aber ärgere, dass irgendwie komische Reaktionen zurückkommen,
dann ist das nicht großartig verwunderlich.
Das heißt, es gibt schon noch die Unterscheidung der Zielgruppen, die muss aber jeder erst mal für sich selber finden und die Sprache ändert sich schon,
je nachdem wohin ich meine Botschaft schicken möchte?
Klar, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sage, okay mir ist es jetzt wahnsinnig wichtig, dass ich auch irgendwie jüngere Leute erreiche mit meiner Kommunikation,
Sie hatten ja jetzt den Kollegin Quaschning ja erwähnt, das ist ein Beispiel für jemanden, der wirklich sehr stark auch gerade auf die jüngeren Zielgruppen geht.
Der macht dann eben entsprechende YouTube-Videos, die sicherlich sich jetzt auch nicht jeder andere angucken würde, aber er sagt, okay das ist jetzt für diese Zielgruppe gedacht.
Und macht dann aber auch noch andere Dinge, die dann vielleicht eher wieder Richtung seiner anderen Rezipientinnen gehen.
Also das meine ich, dass man halt irgendwie natürlich auch eine Sprache, auch ein Medium in einer gewissen Art und Weise diesen Zielen und diesen Zielgruppen anpasst
und dass es natürlich heute ein recht hohes Interesse daran gibt, gerade auch jüngere Menschen zu erreichen und dafür auch die Sprache der Wissenschaft vielleicht dann doch etwas kompliziert ist,
dass wir vielleicht auch gerade in Deutschland eine Wissenschaftssprache benutzen, die nicht so allgemein verständlich ist.
Wenn Sie sich jetzt eben Fachbücher aus dem angelsächsischen Raum anschauen, haben Sie häufig eine ganz andere Sprache und damit schon einen ganz anderen Zugang auch zu den Menschen.
Und ich glaube, dessen muss man sich halt einfach bewusst sein, was natürlich die Sprache auch …
Nicht jede Sprache oder nicht mit jeder Sprache man jeden wie gesagt erreichen kann.
Jetzt gehen wir mal konkret sozusagen auf die Bedürfnisse von Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Wenn man jetzt sich überlegt, okay ich kommuniziere jetzt in bestimme Kanäle rein, Sie haben es schon erwähnt, Alter, Vorbildung oder Interessenlage, das sind alles so Kategorien,
ist auch nicht unbedingt so einen lineare Geschichte und im Zweifelsfall auch so eine größere Matrix, wo man sich dann zurechtfinden muss.
Und man versucht also, jetzt die richtige Sprache zu entwickeln.
Das bedeutet ja erst mal auch, sehr viel Zeit zu investieren, nehme ich an, reinzuhören.
Wie ist denn das, wenn man in einem anderen Alter ist, dann hat man halt die Jugendsprache nicht drauf oder versteht sie auch relativ schnell miss oder kommt dann vielleicht auch schon in dieses Problem,
dass man dann einfach so rüberkommt, dass man sich dann halt einfach nur sinnlos anbiedert und das wirkt dann unter Umständen auch ein bisschen alberner so.
Genau, das darf es auch nicht sein.
Genauso gibt es natürlich dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen von den alten Zeiten geprägte Wissenschaftskreise, den dann eine zu muntere Herangehensweise dann auch irgendwie suspekt vorkommt.
Stellt sich mir eben die Frage, einerseits wie stellt man jetzt diese Werkzeuge für sich richtig ein?
Was würden Sie denn sagen, wie bereitet man sich denn darauf überhaupt vor, also was muss man hier für sich studieren, um sich erst mal in diese Lage zu versetzen nd wie misst man danach den Erfolg?
Also ich glaube, da haben Sie was ganz richtiges gesagt, sich bloß nicht anbiedern.
Also jetzt nicht meinen, dass man jetzt irgendwie in Jugendsprech abdriften muss, weil man jetzt mit Jugendlichen kommuniziert, das um Gottes Willen nicht.
Es muss schon authentisch sein und von daher muss man eben und ich meine, wenn man als Professorin oder als Professor tätig ist, hat man es ja eigentlich ständig mit dieser Generation junger Menschen zu tun
und weiß schon relativ gut wie die ticken und was die mögen und wird auch schnell feststellen, dass dabei eben eine gewisse Authentizität schon sehr wichtig ist.
Und das muss man vielleicht für sich selber feststellen, dass man auch nicht der Typ ist, der vielleicht irgendwie in einem YouTube-Video etwas erklären möchte
und das dann gleich eben in einen breiteren Verteiler hineingibt.
Vielfach ist es so, da geht es schon so Richtung Professionalisierung jetzt auch von Wissenschaftskommunikation, dass es natürlich an den Hochschulen selber,
aber auch von unabhängigen oder mehr oder weniger unabhängigen Beratungen auch Angebote gibt, die man in diesem Bereich nutzen kann, um sich eben da auch schlau zu machen,
dass man eben Tagungen besuchen kann, Workshops mitmachen kann und wie gesagt jetzt auch die Hochschulkommunikation als organisationsunterstützend mit- und wahrnehmen kann,
denn dort sitzen ja auch Leute, die sich jeden Tag mit Wissenschaftskommunikation beschäftigen, die das dann eben vermittelnd tun und die ja auch Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler vermitteln
an Journalisten etc. pp.
Haben Sie denn an der HTW konkrete Angebote für die Mitarbeiter der Universität, um sich genau in diesem Bereich besser schulen zu können?
Also wir haben auf jeden Fall da Möglichkeiten, die könnten immer noch ausgebaut werden, aber in der Tat gibt es da Angebote, genau.
Also beispielsweise zum Thema Umgang mit sozialen Medien, da gibt es dann eben entsprechend gemeinsame Workshops,
wo dann auch die Mitarbeiterinnen aus der Hochschulkommunikation sich mit den Kolleginnen dann auch zusammensetzen und in so einem Workshop eben auch gemeinsam darüber nachdenken,
was ist ein gutes Bild, was da auch ein Studiengang oder ein einzelner Professor nach außen halt abgeben möchte?
Das ist natürlich bei einer Hochschule, die jetzt auch knapp 300 Professorinnen hat und dann auch viele wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterinnen dann am Ende des Tages auch eine Frage begrenzter Ressourcen,
dass man jetzt da nicht jede individuelle Anfrage vielleicht so bedienen kann, aber grundsätzlich gibt es das Angebot.
Und es gibt natürlich auch viele andere Träger, das Berliner Zentrum für Hochschullehre etc., die solche Sachen auch inzwischen im Angebot haben.
Also diese Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten gibt es und die würde ich auch als jemand, der jetzt nicht vielleicht vom Fach kommt, auf jeden Fall mal wahrnehmen,
also einen Workshop mitmachen und dadurch einerseits nimmt einem das vielleicht auch Sorgen, die man hat, in Bezug auf die Nutzung von beispielsweise sozialen Medien
und auf der anderen Seite zeigt es einem aber auch auf, dass es auch keine Rocket Science ist, also dass es auch etwas ist, was man in der Tat lernen kann, wenn man möchte.
Trotzdem hat man oft so den Eindruck, dass Leute, die jetzt tief in ihrer Wissenschaft drin stecken, so aus zwei oder vielleicht sogar noch ein paar mehr Gründen da so sich ein bisschen zurückhalten.
So eine offene Kommunikation nicht suchen, also man könnte sagen, so ein leicht elitärer Ansatz mit, naja das ist ja alles so kompliziert was ich hier mache, das versteht ja sowieso keiner
und ich will eigentlich mich nur mit Leuten unterhalten, die irgendwie auf meinem Level sind, mal so ein bisschen abfällig gesagt.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich auch eine Form der Authentizität an der Stelle, dass man sich quasi dann dieser Diskussion auch gar nicht so richtig stellt.
Also was macht denn diese Authentizität aus und wie sehr darf man dann sein eigenes Plateau oder wie sehr sollte man sein eigenes Plateau verlassen?
Weil es ja kann auch nicht sein, dass man sich jetzt allem vorenthält und sagt, so ihr kommt ja gar nicht an mein Wissen ran, mit euch rede ich gar nicht.
Auf der anderen Seite soll man sich aber auch nicht zu sehr anbiedern.
Wo ist da der Graubereich, in den man vordringen sollte?
Ich meine, die Frage wurde ja auch schon vielen Politikern gestellt, die jetzt in social media dann gegangen sind und wo man sich gefragt hat,
ist das jetzt gut, dass derjenige dort ist oder merkt man nicht, dass der das gar nicht selber macht, sondern dass das irgendwie jemand ganz anderes macht?
Und das merkt man relativ schnell.
Ich glaube, dass wir jetzt heutzutage eigentlich fast alle einen Umgang mit diesen Medien gewohnt sind, aber dass wir nicht erwarten können,
dass jetzt jeder auch jeder Wissenschaftler sich dort äußert.
Das wäre auch, muss man ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, wo würde das hinführen?
Also es gibt eh schon so viel Kommunikation und einen wahnsinnigen Überschuss an Informationen und ich glaube, man muss dann eben in der Tat so etwas dann aufbauen
und dann vielleicht auch eben überlegen und das fand ich zum Beispiel sehr gut auch bei den Scientists for Future, die dann quasi auch eine Gruppe gebildet haben,
dass jetzt auch nicht jeder immer zu allem was sagen muss, sondern die sich halt auch mal abwechseln, die sich auch gegenseitig die Bälle zuspielen.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein sehr kluger, sehr guter Umgang, dass auch deutlich wird, es geht eben nicht nur um die Interessen eines einzelnen,
es ist nicht nur das einzelne Marketing, sondern es geht in der Tat auch um das Thema.
Und das, würde ich sagen, ist natürlich bei der Wissenschaftskommunikation nach wie vor ganz wichtig, dass es nämlich Themen gibt, die ein Wissenschaftler, eine Wissenschaftlerin besetzt,
die sie vermitteln wollen, wo sie auch eine gewisse Mission sozusagen damit verbinden, dass sie zu diesem Thema sprechfähig sind und kompetent sind und das ist so die Grundvoraussetzung.
Und das muss man den Wissenschaftlerinnen auch abnehmen.
Das ist genau das, was dann eben auch authentisch wirkt.
Wenn also jemand nicht nachweisen kann, dass er eben auch schon in einem gewissen Bereich publiziert hat und in dem gewissen Bereich dann eben auch auf wissenschaftlichen Tagungen war etc.,
dann wäre es eben auch nicht authentisch, wenn der sich nach außen stellen würde und sagen würde, ich bin jetzt der große Experte für das Thema X oder Y.
Also dieses eng bei den Themen bleiben, gucken, ob man sich eben mit anderen abstimmen kann und dann in dem Maße eben authentisch sein, dass man sich eben nicht verstellt.
Das kann ich gar nicht genauer beschreiben jetzt, das ist natürlich auch sehr abhängig von den einzelnen Personen, mit denen Sie es da zu tun haben.
Jetzt wollten wir uns ein wenig mal konzentrieren auf die Krisenkommunikation.
Wie passend, dass wir gerade eine Krise haben.
Haben wir eigentlich ständig.
Eigentlich haben wir Dauerkrisen, die Wahrnehmung davon ist bloß, glaube ich, immer sehr unterschiedlich, wann denn nun eine Krise tatsächlich eintrifft.
Klassischerweise, glaube ich, verbindet man so Krisenkommunikation natürlich eher mit der Wirtschaft an der Stelle.
Also keine Ahnung, irgendwie Fabrik ist explodiert, dicke Diskussionen über die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen.
Wurde hier alles richtig getan, wird mit den Opfern richtig umgegangen etc.?
Wir haben da schon viele Firmen scheitern sehen, die dann einfach zum falschen Zeitpunkt das Falsche gesagt haben oder eben auch einfach …
… nichts gesagt haben.
… nichts gesagt haben, genau und sich damit eigentlich dann noch sehr viel tiefer in den Mist gefahren haben als das ohnehin schon stattgefunden hat.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Bewusstsein, was überhaupt erst so in den letzten ein-zwei Jahrzehnten so ein bisschen hochgekommen ist, dass man sich an der Stelle eben schnell vergaloppieren kann
und dass es wichtig ist, sich genau dafür vorzubereiten.
Ich denke, so Krisenkommunikationstraining ist, glaube ich, in der Wirtschaft mittlerweile Standard oder?
Also zumindest bei größeren Unternehmen ist das in der Tat der Fall, aber auch nicht bei jedem mittelständischen Unternehmen wird man feststellen, wenn eine Krise auftritt,
dass die da wirklich gut darauf vorbereitet waren.
Das ist dann häufig auch immer sehr theoretisch, ist ja auch gut so, aber gleichwohl, glaube ich, ist es den Unternehmen bewusst, dass da Dinge passieren können, an denen sie teilweise ja auch gar nicht selber schuld sind.
Ja, schuld muss man ja nicht sein, aber man kann halt schnell als Schuldiger gebrandmarkt werden, wenn man sich einfach nur falsch dazu verhält.
Absolut richtig, genau, ja.
Allein schon weil die anderen die Krisenkommunikation besser beherrschen und in der Lage sind, einem den Buhmann zuzuschieben.
Ja, weil man zu spät reagiert, wie gesagt wir hatten das Thema, gar nicht reagiert, auch das kann eine Strategie sein, die teilweise sogar berechtigt ist.
Also in der Krisenkommunikation ist es schon so, dass es so ein Set an möglichen Strategien gibt und man jetzt nicht sagen kann, es ist gut, wenn man sofort was sagt,
sondern man muss natürlich dann auch wissen, ob man, wenn man sofort was sagt, auch das Richtige sagt oder ob man vielleicht dann doch nochmal eine Stunde länger abwarten soll.
Aber in einer Zeit, in der wir eben durch die sozialen Medien sehr getrieben sind und die Dynamik sehr hoch ist, kann es sich eigentlich niemand leisten und das gilt dann eben genauso gut auch für Krisen,
die in anderen Bereichen passieren, im öffentlichen Bereich etc., da gar keine Stellungnahme abzugeben.
Ist Ihnen denn in der Corona-Krise irgendein Unternehmen durch besonders gute oder schlechte Krisenkommunikation schon aufgefallen?
Ach in der Corona-Zeit habe ich vor allen Dingen wirklich die Kommunikation von anderen Seiten wahrgenommen.
Ich fand die Unternehmen in der Corona-Zeit relativ ruhig.
Also es gab ja dann einige, die irgendwann gesagt haben, dass sie ich auch beteiligen, dass sie jetzt auch gemeinsam an Impfstoffen forschen, auch wenn das vielleicht gar nicht so in ihrem ersten ökonomischen Eigeninteresse ist.
Das hat man dann irgendwann schon wahrgenommen, aber ich glaube, in der Corona-Zeit war die Kommunikation bisher sehr stark bestimmt von der eben eher politischen oder auch Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Genau, das sind ja im Prinzip die drei Akteure, die man jetzt hier auch mal gegeneinander abwägen sollte.
In dem Moment, wo klar war, Krise ist, ist natürlich die Politik in der ersten Reihe.
Hat sich aber ja in diesem Fall mehr oder weniger vom Start weg extrem auf die Wissenschaft berufen oder sich von ihr flankieren lassen, wodurch natürlich die Wissenschaft selbst auch mehr in den Fokus gerät.
Es ist nunmal in dem Moment, wo es um Viren geht, ganz klar, in größerem Maße ein wissenschaftliches Thema oder ich würde sagen, zumindest ist die Akzeptanz dafür, dass es ein wissenschaftliches Thema ist, relativ groß gewesen.
Schön, dass Sie sagen, gewesen.
Ja.
Das hat sich auch schon durchaus verändert.
Ja genau, wie haben Sie denn das wahrgenommen?
Wie hat sich denn das so vor Ihren Augen abgespielt?
Also zunächst mal war es ja in der Tat so, dass es eine ziemlich einheitliche Erzählung, wie man so schön sagt, gab, mit diesem Thema flatten the curve,
dass im Prinzip da alle irgendwie sich hinter gestellt haben und man doch eine hohe, hohe Einheit sehen konnte in den ersten gut vier Wochen.
Jetzt sagen schon die ersten, na das war irgendwie fast gleichgeschaltet, das war kein demokratischer Diskurs.
In der Tat ist in dieser Phase wenig Diskurs gewesen.
Also irgendwann gab es natürlich diejenigen, die ersten, die gesagt haben, man darf jetzt nicht nur an die Gesundheit denken, sondern man muss auch an die Wirtschaft denken.
Aber trotz allem war es doch eine Kommunikation, die so in die gleiche Richtung ging.
Das ist, glaube ich, aber eine Ausnahmesituation und lässt sich in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft, wie wir gerade sehen, auch nicht lange durchhalten, weil dann kommen doch die anderen Meinungen.
Und dann ist natürlich schon jetzt sehr interessant zu beobachten, wie das auch schnell umgeschlagen ist und wie auch die Wissenschaft immer mehr in die Kritik geraten ist
und ja auch sich sehr viel rechtfertigen musste, wie überhaupt Wissenschaft funktioniert.
Also das finde ich einerseits sehr positiv, dass das auch so oft betont werden musste, dass hoffentlich auch mehr Menschen verstehen, dass Wissenschaft eben nicht die endgültigen Wahrheiten hat,
sondern per Definition einen Prozess darstellt, in dem sich dann eben auch Erkenntnisse verändern können.
Das ist erst mal eine, finde ich, richtige und gute Botschaft, aber da muss man natürlich dann jetzt auch sagen, wenn Menschen das Gefühl haben, ach naja gut, so schlimm war das ja jetzt hier alles irgendwie nicht,
dann auch wieder sehr schnell Kritik auch aufkommt, dass es zu langsam geht, dass die Menschen sich da irgendwie schnellere Lockerungen wünschen etc..
So dass plötzlich jetzt wieder ein Pluralismus von Meinungen da ist, vor allen Dingen auch an den harten Rändern, sage ich mal, Befürworter gegen Gegner von Lockerungen etc..
Ich sage immer gerne, es gibt wenig dazwischen.
Also diese argumentative Auseinandersetzung würde meiner Meinung nach eigentlich dazwischen stattfinden müssen, dass man wirklich mal Dinge gegeneinander abwägt,
das wäre auch das, was ich eigentlich auch als die Verantwortung von Wissenschaft sehe und ich finde, dass Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler das auch hier in Deutschland gar nicht schlecht machen.
Dass man natürlich immer noch mehr auch in den Diskurs einbinden könnte, dass sich dann in so einem Diskurs auch Menschen äußern, die eigentlich keine wirklich ernstzunehmenden Wissenschaftler sind,
aber gerade in so einem Moment jetzt auch Oberwasser haben, das merkt man schon auch.
Also insofern hat sich das verlagert, die Öffentlichkeit ist kritischer geworden und das bezieht sich damit durchaus auch auf die Wissenschaft oder die Art und Weise, wie man die Kommunikation von Wissenschaft aber auch Politik wahrnimmt.
Aber grundsätzlich würde ich so mal sagen, war es schon interessant zu sehen, wie schnell auch die Wissenschaft in der Öffentlichkeit eine sehr hohe Resonanz hatte
und man ja auch in Umfragen beispielsweise beim Wissenschaftsbarometer gesehen hat, dass das Vertrauen der Menschen in die Wissenschaft in den anfänglichen Wochen sogar noch gewachsen ist.
Ja, es ist kein Ruhm in Prävention, sagt man ja so schön, also diese Wahrnehmung, dass ja dann irgendwie auf einmal gar nichts gewesen ist, weil ausnahmsweise mal Dinge richtig gemacht wurden,
die ist natürlich generell schwierig und lässt sich so an der Stelle überhaupt nicht so richtig bekämpfen.
Aber um vielleicht nochmal dieses Wechselspiel von Wissenschaft und Politik mehr in den Fokus zu nehmen, ich meine, zunächst einmal ist ja immer in jeder Krise erst mal die Politik gefragt.
Also zumindest in so einer deutschlandweiten Krise, wo es ganz klar dann eben auch um Entscheidungen und eben vor allem um die richtigen Entscheidungen geht.
Wie haben Sie denn das beobachtet, wie die Politik die Wissenschaft eingebunden hat und wie bewerten Sie das?
Also ich glaube, man hat schon gemerkt, dass wir eine Kanzlerin haben, die sehr wissenschaftsnah ist, die selber auch aus einem naturwissenschaftlichen Umfeld kommt
und die in der Tat auch die Wissenschaft sehr schnell mit an Bord geholt hat, um entsprechende Entscheidungen auch vorbereiten zu lassen.
Dass die Entscheidung dann doch von der Politik getroffen werden muss, ist systemimmanent und das kann man definitiv nicht der Wissenschaft dann sozusagen vorwerfen,
sondern die Wissenschaft hat hier in der Tat eine beratende und begleitende Funktion gehabt, wie sie das auch an anderen Stellen hat, aber hier in dieser Form natürlich einmalig,
weil es eben so eine neue unglaublich ungewohnte Situation ist, also eigentlich wirklich das Paradigma einer Krise, die also überraschend auftritt.
Das ist ja auch ein Definitionsmerkmal von Krisen, dass sie eben überraschend auftreten.
Und es gibt natürlich auch Krisen, die sich so anschleichen, wo man schon über Jahre eigentlich wahrnehmen kann, da ist was nicht in Ordnung, wenn wir an die Klimathematik denken.
Aber in diesem Fall hatten wir es wirklich mal mit einer Krise par excellence zu tun, sehr überraschender Eintritt und da ist meine Wahrnehmung, dass in der Tat die Politik die Wissenschaft sehr schnell mit ins Boot geholt hat
und auch für die richtigen Themen sozusagen genutzt hat, denn neben den Virologen, die ja von vornherein gefragt waren, wurde dann ja auch die Leopoldina gefragt,
die ja eben auch ein Spektrum verschiedenster Wissenschaftlerinnen abbildet, weniger Frauen, aber Wissenschaftler.
So dass man an der Stelle zumindest ja auch wieder gesehen hat, man versucht hier auch verschiedene wissenschaftliche Stimmen mit zu hören und in die Entscheidungsfindung mit einzubeziehen.
Ja. Das heißt, zunächst einmal war die Wahrnehmung, Wissenschaft sozusagen Begleiter der Politik, Rückgrat der Entscheidungsfindung, sage ich mal.
Naja, ich meine, es gab ja sogar in den Medien schon sehr interessante Kommentare.
Also dass Herr Drosten dann quasi schon zum Kanzler ausgerufen wurde, daran sieht man schon durchaus natürlich auch wiederum,
dass eine mediale Logik eben auch gerade sehr stark diese Personalisierung liebt und die war eben auch gegeben.
Das hat man ja auch nicht immer, weil Wissenschaftlerinnen ja, wie wir gerade schon besprochen hatten, auch nicht immer diejenigen sind, die als Personen so in den Vordergrund treten,
sondern natürlich mit ihren Themen in Verbindung gebracht werden, aber hier hatten wir plötzlich diese Person und das ist natürlich was, was die Medien lieben.
Und dann ist man sehr sehr schnell bei dieser Personalisierung und vielleicht auch bei einer gewissen Überhöhung dessen, was denn dann die Wissenschaft hier in diesem Moment leisten kann.
Da hat sich der Herr Drosten ja selbst mehrfach sehr kritisch zu geäußert.
Ich denke, so sein Auftreffen im Mainstream und in der totalen Öffentlichkeit hatte für ihn jetzt nicht nur positive Auswirkungen.
Klar, Wahrnehmung der eigenen Wissenschaft, das freut einen natürlich, aber die ganzen Nebeneffekte, die dann eben durch diese Personalisierung auch noch besonders verstärkt werden, waren dann, glaube ich, weniger schön.
Und es gab verschiedene Kommentare von ihm, wo er sich dann doch sehr skeptisch über seine Rolle oder seine wahrgenommene Rolle äußert.
Nicht nur über diese ganz offensichtlichen negativen Nebenwirkungen, wie Morddrohungen und keine Ahnung, was da alles noch zusammenkommen sein dürfte,
sondern dass eben auch diese Wahrnehmung entstand, es wäre jetzt die Wissenschaft die entscheidet.
Und er hat ja auch immer wieder betont, dass es eben die Politik ist, die entscheidet und dass er diese Entscheidung ja einerseits nicht trifft, gar nicht treffen kann,
aber dass auch seine Beratungshaltung nicht so ist mit, das ist das, was ihr entscheiden müsst, sondern eher ein, hier sind die Fakten, auf denen ihr eine Entscheidung treffen könnt.
Genau, ja.
Kommt das so rüber?
Also ist das eine Botschaft, die in der Öffentlichkeit auch verstanden wird?
Also ich würde denken, dass ja viele der Medien das dann auch aufgegriffen haben und eben auch in dieser Form weiter reflektiert haben.
Da muss man jetzt natürlich auch differenzieren, mit welchen Medien wir es zu tun haben, sind es die sozialen Medien oder sind es die Online-Medien, die auf sehr schnelles Klicken aus sind,
wo man eben eher eine effekthaschende Überschrift braucht oder sind es eben die Medien und da hat man es dann aber gesehen in der Zeit, in der Süddeutschen, in der FAZ,
dass auch die Rolle der Wissenschaft sehr stark mit reflektiert wurde und ich glaube, darüber das schon angekommen ist.
Ob das jetzt die Öffentlichkeit per se so wahrgenommen hat, müsste man in der Tat mal schauen, was Studien dazu sagen werden.
Es gibt jetzt ja gerade sehr viele Studien, die sich mit der Wahrnehmung von Corona oder mit den Auswirkungen von Corona auf die verschiedensten Lebensbereiche beschäftigen,
da wird sicherlich dazu auch mal etwas kommuniziert werden.
Aber in der Tat hatte ich so das Gefühl, dass die klassischen, die seriösen Medien auch in irgendeiner Form das mit reflektieren und damit auch in die Öffentlichkeit zu tragen, wie Sie es gerade beschrieben hatten.
Übrigens ist das trotzdem nochmal ganz interessant, weil wir gerade so darüber geredet hatte, welche Systeme sind es irgendwie, die in dieser Corona-Krise eine Rolle gespielt haben?
Wir hatten jetzt die Wissenschaft, die Wirtschaft und die Politik, aber ich finde so ein ganz entscheidendes System sind im Prinzip die Medien.
Und natürlich sind die auch von wirtschaftlichen Interessen geprägt, zum Teil jedenfalls und da glaube ich, die Rolle der Medien in dieser Konstellation, die lohnt es auf jeden Fall sich auch nochmal genauer anzuschauen,
um eben genau das auch feststellen zu können, inwiefern Wissenschaftskommunikation sich in Zukunft verändern wird,
inwiefern Wissenschaftlerinnen vielleicht sagen werden, ich möchte nicht, dass mir so was passiert wie dem Drosten, ich möchte eigentlich forschen und jetzt nicht jeden Tag da draußen stehen müssen
und irgendwie mein Gesicht in die Kamera halten, so dass das durchaus einen Effekt haben wird.
Ich hatte jetzt gerade hier in der letzten Sendung Gespräch mit Jan-Hinrik Schmidt, auch viel über Medienkommunikation generell und den Wandel der Medien über die Zeit gesprochen.
Und wenn sich irgendwas nennenswert verändert hat, dann ist es ja eben auch die zur Verfügung stehenden Medien und durch die digitalen Medien und social media eben auch diese Änderung der Verbreitungskanäle.
Jetzt ist es ja ganz interessant, dass in diesem Fall ausgerechnet ein Podcast, ja ein Wort, was man vor ein paar Jahren noch den Leuten erklären musste, wurde einem ja jetzt von der Kanzlerin und allen anderen
und nicht zuletzt dann eben auch durch diesen Coronavirus Podcast so ein allgemeiner Begriff, dass man es jetzt wahrscheinlich niemandem mehr jemals erklären muss.
Das muss Sie doch sehr freuen oder?
Das hat mir ein gewisses Lächeln aufgezogen, gar keine Frage.
Genugtuung.
Aber ich habe damit eh gerechnet, dass das irgendwann passieren wird, vielleicht aber nicht unbedingt auf diese Art und Weise.
Aber das Interessante daran ist ja, dass das eben, obwohl es ein Projekt war, was vom NDR durchgeführt wurde, sie es ja jetzt gar nicht so sehr primär da in so ein klassisches Format gedrängt haben,
sondern eigentlich bewusst ein neues Format gewählt haben, in dem eben eine andere Kommunikation auch möglich ist.
Klar, insbesondere Hörerinnen und Hörer dieses Podcasts werden das schon lange wissen, dass eben diese Ausführlichkeit und dieses Abwägende und dieses doch etwas Meinungslastigere,
was man in Podcasts häufig findet oder zumindest finden kann und sollte, eine andere Qualität auch in der Kommunikation hat.
Und da wir jetzt vielleicht auch über diese Top-Hype auch dieses Podcasts schon ein bisschen hinaus sind und die Leute sich so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt haben, dass da jetzt nicht jeden Tag neue bahnbrechende Informationen kommen
und ich glaube, Herr Drosten auch so ein bisschen gegengesteuert hat und einfach so, ich mache jetzt hier mal so weiter hardcore meine Wissenschaft und jetzt quatschen wir mal so intensiv hier über Studien,
bis wirklich alle die, die nicht hierher gehören auch wieder abgeschaltet haben, man eben in seinen eigenen Formaten und darauf wollte ich jetzt so ein bisschen hinaus,
doch ganz andere Steuerungsmöglichkeiten hat, als wenn man sich eben ausschließlich immer auf diese Formate der totalen Verkürzung, die die Leute gewohnt sind und permanent kommunizieren, einlässt.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, diese Erkenntnisse, dass man eigentlich mit einem Medium auch die eigene Zielgruppe sehr viel mehr steuern kann, das ist doch etwas, was ich jetzt langsam rumsprechen sollte.
Tut es das?
Ja genau und da sind wir jetzt bei dem professionellen Kommunikationsmanagement wieder, also die Überlegung, wen will ich ansprechen und dann,
was sind die Kanäle, mit denen ich diese Menschen erreichen kann.
Das ist in der Tat ja eine entscheidende Frage, vor der ich stehe, wenn ich jede Art von Kommunikation plane und sie nicht nur einfach passieren lasse.
Und dass es in der Tat natürlich jetzt heute eine größere Vielfalt da vielleicht gibt an öffentlichen Medien oder zumindest auch an den verschiedensten Online-Medien.
Auf der anderen Seite, was ich ganz interessant finde, jetzt kommen wir mal vom Podcast kurz mal weg, dass Wissenschaftlerinnen auch signalisieren,
was sie eigentlich vor allen Dingen in den letzten Jahren als sehr gewinnbringend erlebt haben in Bezug auf Wissenschaftskommunikation ist, zu den Leuten zu gehen, und zwar in persönliche Dialoge.
Das ist anstrengend, das ist auch nicht immer nett und einfach und das bedeutet, dass man sich dann halt eben auch mal aus der Hochschule irgendwie wegbewegen muss,
aber dieses auch mal bewusst die Zentren verlassen, wo wir eh immer in unseren Filterblasen sind.
Also als Sie mich gerade gefragt haben, wie ich das wahrgenommen hätte, wie die Öffentlichkeit das wahrgenommen hat, da habe ich auch wieder gedacht,
naja ich kann Ihnen das aus meiner Filterblase heraus beantworten, aber die ist eben auch begrenzt, weil ich eben auch natürlich bestimmte Medien rezipiere und andere wiederum nicht.
Und das ist ganz interessant, weil damit hat natürlich Drosten auf eine gewisse Art und Weise jetzt mit diesem Podcast dann auch mal gebrochen,
weil darüber natürlich jetzt schon auch die Möglichkeit war, nochmal an ein anderes Publikum heranzukommen, wird man das sicherlich auch auswerten.
Das ist jetzt natürlich auch ein super bekannter Podcast, ob das jetzt bei anderen so funktionieren würde, ist jetzt nochmal eine andere Frage.
Aber um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, die Maßnahmen, die wir zur Verfügung haben, auch im Bereich Wissenschaftskommunikation, sind wirklich vielfältig.
Und es kann auch sein, dass ich mal irgendwo in eine Volkshochschule gehe auf dem Land und da mal einen Vortrag halte und das für mich als total gewinnbringend empfinde,
weil ich merke, ich habe da irgendwie Leute erreicht, die ich jetzt über Twitter gar nicht erreiche.
Also insofern glaube ich, ist das für mich ganz wichtig, dass wir bei Wissenschaftskommunikation auch nicht immer nur über die reichweitenstarken Medien reden,
also über irgendwie wieviele Follower hat jemand jetzt bei Twitter oder wieviele Zuhörer gibt es in dem Podcast.
Das sind natürlich quantitativ interessante Zahlen, die auch was aussagen und natürlich möchte jeder irgendwie möglichst viele Follower haben, aber auf der anderen Seite kann das eben unter dem Gesichtspunkt,
wie vermittele ich eigentlich das was ich tue und sorge auch dafür, dass Wissenschaft eben auch andere Menschen erreicht als diejenigen, die eh schon damit zu tun haben,
kann das sehr viel erfüllender sein, da auch auf andere Formate zu setzen.
Also quasi eine qualitative Messung einer Zielgruppe?
Ich bin eh ein Freund von qualitativer Forschung, genau, insofern würde ich immer sagen, ja genau.
Und das muss natürlich dann am Ende des Tages, wenn man das jetzt als Organisation sieht, keine Ahnung, eine Forschungsorganisation, die sich jetzt vornimmt, sie möchten auch in der Wissenschaftskommunikation präsenter sein,
dann muss man das natürlich über die Vielfalt der Wissenschaftlerinnen sich dann eben auch anschauen und auch entsprechend würdigen.
Also ich finde, das ist eben auch ganz wichtig, dass nach innen das in die Organisation hinein transportiert wird, dass es da eben jetzt nicht nur den einen Wert oder die eine richtige Strategie gibt.
Da sind wir wieder beim Thema, was passt zu mir als Wissenschaftler, was ist authentisch, womit kann ich mich identifizieren, wo habe ich auch das Gefühl, einen Mehrwert liefern zu können,
weil ich vielleicht jemand bin, der gerne mit den Leuten in die Diskussion geht oder bin ich jemand, der sagt, um Gottes Willen nein, aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, mal bei irgendwie einem Podcast mitzumachen
oder mal irgendwie bei einer Talkshow dabei zu sein so.
Oder eben auch eigene Formate aufzubauen.
Oder das.
Weil das ja dann … ich meine, was damit mitkommt, was, glaube ich, oft nicht gesehen wird ist, dass eigene Kanäle auch bedeuten, dass man damit ja auch eigene Communitys aufbaut.
Wenn man immer nur zu Gast ist so, dann ist es ja nichts eigenes.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man selber gestaltet und wo man selber diese Kanäle auch pflegt und dann natürlich auch zwangsläufig auch weiterentwickelt und sich, glaube ich, auch sehr viel mehr Gedanken darüber macht,
wie man dann sendet und Feedback erhält, kann man ja dann auch über die Kommunikation als solche sehr viel mehr auch lernen und dann eben mitnehmen.
Absolut, da bin ich total bei Ihnen.
Und ich glaube, auch jeder, der das irgendwie anfängt, der wird auch schnell Feuer fangen und das habe ich ja auch bei dem Kollegen Quaschning gesehen, der dann sehr vielfältige eigene Formate auch kreiert hat
und in der Tat ja, glaube ich, auch Freude daran gefunden hat, das dann weiterzutreiben, neben dem, was er sonst so in Forschung und Lehre macht.
Ich finde das immer sehr beeindruckend, wenn ich sehe, wie aktiv er da unterwegs ist, auch mit seiner eigenen Kommunikation.
Genau, aber man muss dabei auch wissen, das wissen Sie, das weiß ich, dass so was jetzt auch nicht nebenbei zu machen ist mal eben so, sondern dass das eben aufwändig ist, dass man auch dranbleiben muss.
Also wenn ich jetzt so einen eigenen Kanal habe, ein Blog oder ähnliches und nach zwei Beiträgen dann abbreche und nach einem halben Jahr irgendwie mal denke, ach ich könnte mal wieder was machen.
Man muss halt schon dann auch einen gewissen langen Atem mitbringen, gerade auch bis man sich so was aufgebaut hat, auch das geht ja nicht von jetzt auf gleich.
Nicht jeder Wissenschaftler wird es ja irgendwie schaffen, dass er sofort hunderte von Anhängern da hinter sich versammelt oder Menschen, die das interessiert, was er tut.
Also insofern man braucht da schon auch einen langen Atem und das hat halt eben auch mit Arbeit zu tun.
Hat es mit Sicherheit, andererseits die Corona-Krise hat ja noch so einen anderen interessanten Fallout, dass man eben sich jetzt nicht mehr so auf Konferenzen treffen kann und das ist ja so ein bisschen die Urvorstellung der wissenschaftlichen Debatte.
Ich stelle meine Paper hin, ich hänge da mein Poster auf, ich stelle mich da zehn Minuten davor und quatsche mit den Leuten und man freut sich, wenn man dann im Laufe von drei-vier Tagen in so einer relativ aufwendigen Reise mit zehn Leuten gesprochen hat.
Jetzt stellen alle fest so, aha digital kann man sich ja auch ganz interessant unterhalten, Videokonferenzen sind jetzt so Standard und auch die Totalverweigerer müssen jetzt mitmachen und merken,
dass es dann vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm ist, vielleicht merken sie auch, dass es schon immer so schlimm war wie sie immer dachten.
Aber man merkt mindestens eine gewisse Gewöhnung oder vielleicht eben auch eine Akzeptanz macht sich auf jeden Fall in vielen Bereichen breit.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, dass ja Kommunikation auch Debatte ist.
Dass ja der Diskurs in der Kommunikation ja eigentlich ein fester Bestandteil ist.
Und die Wissenschaft, die immer so für sich selbst ja so hoch aufhängt, ja wir sind die, die Erkenntnisse durch eine offene Debatte über Informationen haben, in Form von Papers, die dann auf Konferenzen vorgestellt und diskutiert werden,
müssten sich ja dann eigentlich in dieser tatsächlichen unmittelbaren direkten Kommunikation eigentlich gleich zu Hause fühlen oder?
Das impliziert irgendwie so ein bisschen, dass es Ihrer Meinung nach anders ist.
Also dass es nicht über eigene Kanäle gemacht wird, darauf wollte ich ja hinaus.
Ja. Genau, also ich glaube schon, dass natürlich Wissenschaft da wo sie stattfindet auch immer unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen stattfindet.
Wenn Sie bei diesen Fachkonferenzen sind, dann ist das ja auch eine Community von Leuten, die sich immer wieder trifft und zum Teil sind die Debatten, die man sich dann dort auch anhören darf, auch wiederkehrende Debatten.
Ja.
Also der Austausch ist manchmal schon auch ein bisschen was bekanntes, also manchmal fehlt mir da auch durchaus die Querperspektive oder habe das Gefühl, die ist gar nicht so unbedingt gewünscht.
Die Fachgesellschaften, es gibt auch immer spezifischere, immer kleinere Gruppierungen, ob da irgendwie immer noch so viel Debatte wirklich stattfindet, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber in der Tat sollte das eigentlich diesem Prinzip nahekommen, nur ist es wie gesagt so, bei der Konferenz habe ich da irgendwie einen Austausch auf Augenhöhe mit Menschen,
deren Argumentation auch sich auf einer fachlichen Ebene bewegt, das ist was anderes, als wenn ich jetzt eine Debatte auf Twitter oder Facebook führe, wo mir dann vielleicht auch mit …
ja wo ich auch mit Aussagen konfrontiert bin, die wirklich überhaupt gar keine fachliche Qualität mehr haben, wie gehe ich denn damit um?
Wie gehe ich damit um, wenn ich irgendwie angegriffen werden plötzlich als Person?
Wir hatten diese verschiedenen Ebenen von Kommunikation ganz am Anfang.
Bei einer Fachkonferenz gehe ich ja davon aus, dass wir alle auf einer fachlichen Ebene miteinander diskutieren.
Das kann ich aber in diesem medialen Raum nicht so einfach tun, es sei denn ich habe irgendwie ein sehr spezifisches fachliches Online-Magazin oder ein Online-Blog, wo ich eben weiß,
da ist eine bestimmte Fachcommunity zu Hause.
Aber insofern glaube ich schon, dass es nochmal eine andere Qualität hat und dass man sich dessen auch bewusst sein muss, wenn man sagt, naja gut, Diskurs ist ja meins, kenne ich doch aus der Wissenschaft nicht anders,
führe ich dann einfach genauso in den sozialen Medien weiter, das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, ich wollte nicht auf die sozialen Medien so sehr hinaus, weil die sind ja dann in dem Sinne auch keine eigenen Kanäle, sondern in dem Moment, wo man das selber gestaltet, wo man selber quasi die Moderation übernimmt.
Ja, aber selbst wenn Sie es irgendwo selber gestalten, müssen Sie auch in irgendeiner Form es weiter verbreiten.
Wo verbreiten Sie es?
Wenn ich es jetzt auf YouTube gestalte, habe ich einen YouTube-Kanal.
Wenn ich den jetzt nicht als Closed Shop mache, können da ja auch alle möglichen Menschen drauf.
Oder was meinen Sie mit eigenen Medien?
Naja, also in dem Moment, wo ich das Gespräch suche und Dialoge.
Ich meine, das, was wir hier jetzt auch machen, ist ja im Prinzip genauso eine Debatte und so ein Dialog, ein Ring um Deutung und Wahrheiten und eben auch Meinungen und das ist ja sozusagen der Inhalt,
der Kanal ist ja am Ende nur die Ausspielung.
Also dass man selber sich seine Gesprächspartner sucht, dass man selber versucht, das als Teil seiner Forschung vielleicht auch zu verstehen.
Das ist etwas, was ich selten sehe.
Die Kommunikation ist immer ausgelagert.
So ich mache jetzt meine Forschung und wenn ich die Tür das nächste Mal wieder aufmache, dann kommuniziere ich jetzt mal mit der Öffentlichkeit, aber jetzt will die Tür wieder zumachen, weil ich muss jetzt wieder forschen.
Aber dass ja Kommunikation selber auch Forschung sein kann, ein fester Bestandteil, ist vielleicht etwas, was noch nicht so ganz präsent ist in der ganzen Debatte.
Ja, finde ich einen super spannenden Gedanken und kann ich Ihnen, glaube ich, auch nur zustimmen, wenn ich das jetzt aus meinen Erfahrungen heraus reflektiere,
dass vielleicht gerade auch diejenigen, die an diesem Diskurs und der Diskussion Interesse haben sollten, doch häufig auffallend ruhig sind.
Also es gab, glaube ich, im letzten Jahr mal irgendwann einen Artikel in der Zeit, da ging es darum, inwiefern sich denn auch Fachgesellschaften aus der Germanistik oder andere
eben zu bestimmten Entwicklungen auch im Rahmen der Flüchtlingsdebatte und anderer Themen äußern und dass da doch relativ wenig kommt.
Und gerade wenn Debatten ja eben auch über Sprache oder über visuelle Kommunikation vorangetrieben werden, würde man natürlich das schon erwarten.
Da sind die Wissenschaften zum Teil in der Tat, glaube ich, noch in einem anderen Jahrhundert unterwegs.
Was, um nochmal kurz auf den Podcast mit Christian Drosten zurückzukommen bzw. das gilt im Prinzip eigentlich auch für alle anderen Produktionen, also einen virologischen Podcast zu haben,
das gehört ja heutzutage schon zum guten Ton und ich finde das auch gut, dass so viele Wissenschaftler auf so eine neue Art und Weise auch sichtbar geworden, weil sie natürlich auch streitbarer werden.
Vor allem ist auch immer ganz interessant zu sehen, wie dieser dünne Grad, auf dem marschiert wird, zwischen, ich präsentiere Erkenntnisse aus Studien, die sozusagen so die reine wissenschaftliche Idealvorstellung sind mit,
ich habe das gelesen, ich habe mir darüber Gedanken gemacht, das sind meine Schlüsse oder das ist das, was sich hier verifizierbar, unbestreitbar herauslesen lässt,
aber dann man doch sehr schnell auch in so einen Bereich der weichen Interpretationen bis hin zu Meinungen kommt.
Da kann man dann eben gerade Herrn Drosten auch immer wieder dabei beobachten, wie er sagt, ja aber das ist jetzt wirklich nur meine Meinung, dass das jetzt mal bitte überhaupt nicht falsch verstanden wird.
Was ich sehr gut verstehen kann, weil ich glaube, bei dieser großen öffentlichen Beobachtung ist es nochmal besonders wichtig.
Frage ist für mich, wie schlimm ist das eigentlich, Meinungen hier mit in diesen wissenschaftlichen Diskurs reinzubringen?
Also zunächst mal, ich bin geprägt von der Schule des Konstruktivismus.
In Münster haben wir Kommunikationswissenschaften mit diesem sehr stark konstruktivistischen Ansatz studiert damals.
Und da war irgendwie immer schon klar, naja es ist eine konstruierte Wirklichkeit und Menschen haben auch ihre eigene Wirklichkeit und schaffen sich auch ihre eigenen Fakten.
Und selbst wenn ich Fakten präsentiere, schon die Art und Weise wie ich Fakten interpretiere, ist ja auch schon wiederum eine Form von Interpretation.
Also insofern würde ich sagen, die Wahrheit und damit auch sozusagen die Fakten alleine gibt es irgendwie nicht.
Die Objektivität, sondern das ist ja auch was, was man in den Wissenschaften, deswegen ist man da so trainiert drauf, dass man das immer wieder betont,
dass es eben jetzt gerade vielleicht nicht faktisch abgesichert ist oder dass es in dem Fall eben noch keine zweite Studie gibt, die das auch bestätigt hat,
das finde ich aber eigentlich sehr …
also ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir Menschen öfter uns daran erinnern und damit das quasi auch in der Kommunikation mit reflektieren, auch wenn wir miteinander kommunizieren,
jetzt gar nicht mehr nur über wissenschaftliche Themen.
Und ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass Wissenschaftler und das haben wir ja in dieser Klimadebatte gesehen, auch durchaus eine Meinung mit vertreten können.
Das sind Menschen und die beschäftigen sich mit Themen und wenn die sich mit diesen Themen beschäftigen und irgendwie erkennen, da geht gerade irgendwas richtig schief,
weil eben die Politik bestimmte Dinge nicht sieht oder weil in der Wirtschaft eben bestimmte Entwicklungen ignoriert werden, dass ich da auch als Wissenschaftler eine Meinung zu haben darf.
Da würde ich sagen, ja auf jeden Fall.
Dann aber bitte auch eine Meinung, die ich in irgendeiner Form nach wie vor begründen kann und wenn sozusagen die Meinung, also wenn andere eine andere Meinung vertreten,
dass ich dann auch in der Lage sein muss, darauf in der Diskussion einzugehen.
Und dann zumindest vielleicht sagen zu können, gut das ist nicht meine Meinung, aber ich kann das irgendwie verstehen, nachvollziehen oder man kann sich auch irgendwie näher kommen,
argumentativ austauschen, das ist natürlich auch wieder so ein Idealbild, was es dann gibt, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, Wissenschaftlerinnen sind Menschen und es gibt nicht die Wahrheit,
insofern ist es auch eigentlich ganz gut, wenn so ein Bild vielleicht auch ein bisschen entzaubert wird.
Der große weiße Gott, der da steht, der Arzt, das ist auch ein Mensch und insofern ja, warum sollen Menschen, also auch andere Menschen das auch nicht so wahrnehmen können?
Wird da vielleicht auch einer gewissen Verletzlichkeit, die Menschen da auch mitbringen.
Ich glaube, wir erleben hier eine ganz interessante Zeit, wie sich auch so ein Kampf um die Deutungshoheit entwickelt.
Bisher waren so die Inhaber der großen Kanäle am Ende immer die, die entscheiden darüber, wie irgendwas wahrgenommen wird.
Man kann komplizierte Sachverhalte, wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse bemüht formulieren und versuchen zu beschreiben, aber wenn man eben dann diesen Endkanal nicht unter Kontrolle hat,
dann passiert dann halt irgendwas und das hat ja auch bei vielen Wissenschaftlern oft auch, denke ich, für Frust gesorgt.
So man wird nicht verstanden etc..
Jetzt gibt es natürlich diesen immer ein wenig im Schatten stehenden Wissenschaftsjournalismus, dessen Aufgabe, glaube ich, bisher auch immer war, im Wesentlichen Wissenschaft so zu übersetzen,
dass es eben das überlebt, dort in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung noch korrekt wahrgenommen zu werden.
Durch die ganzen Verschiebungen und die größere Aufmerksamkeit frage ich mich, was bedeutet das jetzt für den Wissenschaftsjournalismus?
Auf der einen Seite sieht man ja, dass auch wissenschaftsjournalistische Outlets, besonders so auf YouTube etc., auch so eine eigene Dominanz auf einmal entwickeln können, weil die einfach populär sind, gut gemacht sind
und eben auch sehr viel mehr in die Tiefe gehen, vielleicht ist auch dieser Podcast ein ähnliches Beispiel dafür.
Wie ist Ihre Wahrnehmung vom Wissenschaftsjournalismus und ist der jetzt auch neu herausgefordert?
Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Also ich glaube schon, der Wissenschaftsjournalismus war immer wichtig, aber er war immer so ein Nischenthema und wurde ja dann auch eben eher in die späten Abendstunden verdrängt
oder auf die letzten Seiten der Zeitungen.
Und da sehen wir, glaube ich, jetzt, dass diese Verschränkung von Themen, also Politik und Wirtschaft, Politik und Wissenschaft, dass diese Verschränkungen auch mehr als eine Berechtigung dafür sind,
dass der Wissenschaftsjournalismus gestärkt wird und da auch Wissenschaftsjournalistinnen weiter ausgebildet werden, das, glaube ich, ist schon etwas, was wir hoffentlich aus dieser Krise mitnehmen.
Es geht um das Einordnen, es geht darum, komplexe Zusammenhänge darzustellen.
Dafür braucht man wahrscheinlich auch mal mehr Zeit, was sicherlich auch im Journalismus in den letzten Jahren, daran hat es gemangelt an dieser Ressource.
Dass man aber jetzt eben auch feststellt, wie wichtig es ist, solche Themen zu begleiten, auch die Politik dabei zu begleiten, wie sie mit wissenschaftlichen Entscheidungen umgeht etc..
Das sind alles Themen, mit denen sich der Wissenschaftsjournalismus auseinandersetzen kann und soll.
Insofern hoffe ich sehr, dass das sich positiv auswirkt für diesen Berufszweig.
Denn Wissenschaftskommunikation in der Tat kann nicht nur die selbst vermittelte Kommunikation aus den Forschungseinrichtungen oder von den Wissenschaftlerinnen sein,
sondern Wissenschaftskommunikation braucht auch die Fremddarstellung durch den Journalismus.
Denken Sie, das so wie man über Wissenschaftsgeschichte vielleicht viel lernen sollte, egal was man wissenschaftlich studiert, auch Wissenschaftsjournalismus zu so einer Art Grundausbildung gehören könnte für eine wissenschaftliche Karriere beliebiger Art?
Also ich glaube auf jeden Fall, Wissenschaftskommunikation, ich weiß nicht, ob gleich Wissenschaftsjournalismus, aber ich würde sagen, in der Wissenschaftskommunikation ist der Wissenschaftsjournalismus dann ja auch mit aufgehoben
und ich glaube, ja, das Thema braucht es auf jeden Fall, wie Sie schon sagten, Wissenschaftsgeschichte oder überhaupt auch Wissenschaftsphilosophie finde ich unglaublich wichtig.
Versuche ich auch mit meinen Studierenden immer zu machen, in jeden Kurs irgendwie einzubinden am Anfang des Studiums.
Und so könnte man mit Sicherheit das Thema Wissenschaftskommunikation auch noch als so ein Querschnittsthema, vielleicht gerade auch interdisziplinär fände ich das sehr sehr spannend,
dass auch Studierender verschiedener Disziplinen das dann mal miteinander reflektieren.
Was heißt das den für Ingenieure, für Naturwissenschaftler, vielleicht dann aber auch für die Geisteswissenschaftler da auch ein gemeinsames, also auch dieses Verständnis dafür zu haben.
Denn das muss man auch sagen, wir haben jetzt immer so über die Wissenschaftskommunikation gesprochen, wir haben diese verschiedenen Disziplinen, die näher dran sind
oder nicht so nahe dran sind, die teilweise auch vielleicht eine unterschiedliche Vorstellung haben davon, was das denn eigentlich ist Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Und ich glaube, dieses Verständnis, wenn man das schon bei Studierenden, erst recht aber dann auch bei Nachwuchswissenschaftlerinnen, die übrigens da sehr sehr offen für sind,
wenn man das als ein quasi Weiterbildungselement oder auch curriculare Inhalte berücksichtigt, fände ich sehr sehr gut und wichtig auch in der Tat.
An dieser Stelle ist es, glaube ich, mal ganz angemessen zu sagen, wann wir uns hier unterhalten, weil sich die Dinge ja dann doch immer noch relativ schnell ändern, bevor wir hier im falschen Kontext landen,
also heute ist der 18. Mai, wo wir sprechen.
Gefühlt ist Deutschland so ein bisschen in dem Modus mit Krise, ja okay, jetzt machen wir aber mal wieder was anderes.
Das heißt, wir wechseln gerade so gefühlt von Akutfall, Notalarm, alle bringen sich in Sicherheit und man achtet halt jetzt mal ganz konkret auf das, was die Wissenschaftler in Anführungsstrichen einem jetzt sozusagen mitgegeben haben,
weil man das unmittelbar auch annimmt in diesem grundalarmierten Zustand, vermittelt durch die Politik etc. ganz klar.
Wir haben ja auch schon angedeutet so, ändert sich jetzt so ein bisschen.
Jetzt wird das alles relativiert.
Man merkt auch, eine Gesellschaft lässt sich nicht beliebig lange einfach in so einem Notmodus halten, zumindest solange man nicht das Gefühl hat, dass die Krise nach wie vor existiert.
Und jetzt haben wir ja dann auch den nächsten Brückenschlag gemacht, weil so was, so eine über einem schwebenden Damokles-Krise, die keiner so richtig sehen will, weil keiner schaut nach oben,
haben wir ja mit dem Klimawandel nun schon lange.
Und die Wissenschaft tut sich extrem schwer oder vielleicht tut sie sich nicht schwer, aber die Öffentlichkeit ist sehr schwer zu erreichen und damit auch die Politik, ist sehr schwer zu erreichen,
diese nicht unmittelbar wahrnehmbare Krisenlage als solche auch anzunehmen und dementsprechend auch zu handeln.
Ähnlich ist es ja jetzt überhaupt auch mit dieser zweiten Phase, in der wir uns jetzt offensichtlich befinden, nämlich dass wir nach wie vor die Bedrohung haben durch das Virus, die aber nicht akut ist,
weil wir es irgendwie eingedämmt haben, trotzdem aber Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen, im Idealfall die richtigen Maßnahmen, um eben nicht wieder da zu landen, wo wir schon mal waren.
Und das alles macht es natürlich jetzt schwer.
Wie nehmen Sie das wahr?
Also was könnte jetzt eine richtige Kommunikation sein der Wissenschaft in die Öffentlichkeit, aber natürlich auch in die Politik, die beides entsprechend befeuern kann?
Also was müsste sich in der Kommunikation ändern, damit diese Themen eine andere Wahrnehmung erhalten?
Ja, das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Am Ende des Tages, wenn ich die beantworten könnte, vielleicht wäre ich dann schon an einer ganz anderen Stelle.
Wäre die Welt schon gerettet. Ich weiß.
Nein, in der Tat stelle ich mir die Frage auch, weil man sich ja gefragt hat, was kann man jetzt lernen aus diesen ersten Wochen und Monaten der Corona-Krise für das Thema Klima?
Oder anders gesagt, sind das zwei völlig unterschiedliche Themen?
Und ich sehe das ähnlich wie Sie, sobald dieses Thema von mir persönlich wieder ein bisschen weiter weggerückt ist, nehme ich das vielleicht nicht mehr so ernst oder so wahr.
Und das ist, glaube ich, bei dem Klimathema das unglaublich schwierige, weil es a) unglaublich komplex ist und weil ich b) einfach für mein eigenes unmittelbares Leben diese Gefahr eben noch nicht so wahrnehmen kann
oder noch nicht sehe, also jetzt irgendwie, das Wasser steht hier schon vor Berlin, also sehe ich, da ist irgendwie was schlimmes da.
Das ist, glaube ich, in so Krisen in der Tat ein Problem.
Man sagt ja auch, man hat so diese latenten Krisen und das scheint jetzt auch bei Corona ja der Fall zu sein, eine Krise, die irgendwie weiter da bleibt, die latent da bleibt
und ich glaube, was man nur machen kann oder was heißt nur, aber was man machen kann und sollte natürlich ist, dass man weiterhin gerade jetzt als Wissenschaftlerin und Wissenschaftler sich Gehör verschafft,
die Scientist for Future machen das ja sehr beständig, auch jetzt während der Corona-Krise haben die auch nicht von ihrem Thema abgelassen und haben auch gesagt,
Mensch guckt euch doch jetzt mal an, plötzlich fliegen so viel weniger Flugzeuge, man sieht, das CO2 in der Luft wird alles irgendwie, die Luft wird besser etc. pp., guckt mal, es sind direkte Auswirkungen.
Ich glaube, das ist halt eben so dieser Punkt, diese direkten Auswirkungen auf das Leben der Menschen irgendwo zu finden, das hilft natürlich unglaublich bei der Kommunikation.
Ob es am Ende des Tages dabei hilft, dass jetzt die Politik die Entscheidungen so trifft, weiß man nicht, weil das haben wir ja jetzt auch gelernt, Politik ist eben ein Abwägen von Interessen
und von verschiedenen Interessen und das hat die Politik in der Klimadiskussion natürlich auch immer schon gesagt, dass es eben auch andere Interesse da abzuwägen gibt
und das sehen wir jetzt in der Corona-Krise auch wieder.
Also insofern ich kann Ihnen da leider jetzt keine glasklare Antwort geben, was man machen muss, damit das sozusagen alles gut wird, wenn man so will.
Aber ich glaube, im Gespräch zu bleiben, immer wieder auch zu gucken, was sind jetzt gerade aktuelle Erkenntnisse, die wir haben, die darstellen, was passiert da gerade auf dieser Welt,
und das Ganze dann auch durchaus in Bilder zu bringen, die Menschen aufrütteln, die Menschen wahrnehmen, das ist dann natürlich so der nächste Schritt.
Da sind wir vielleicht auch wieder beim Wissenschaftsjournalismus, der solche Themen ja auch über eine gewisse Zeit mal begleiten kann.
Aber, um mal so ein bisschen einen anderen Hut aufzusetzen, man könnte es ja auch umdrehen und sagen, ja gut, Corona-Virus, da war die Reaktion klar, weil da war der Bösewicht klar.
Man hatte die unmittelbare Bedrohung, ihr werdet alle sterben etc..
In gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja auch so eine unterschwellige Botschaft in dem Klimawandel, aber irgendwo greift sie nicht.
Weil sie nicht so greifbar ist.
Vielleicht müsste man sie ja dann in der Kommunikation greifbarer machen.
Also in irgendeiner Form plastischer darstellen.
Ich will jetzt nicht mit Hollywood kommen, aber in der Inszenierung von dramatischen Krisen haben die ja einige Erfahrung und zeigen immer wieder, dass es eben durchaus möglich ist, eine Story zu entwickeln, eine Darstellung zu machen.
Vielleicht könnte man das der Wissenschaft vorwerfen, dass sie an der Stelle nicht kreativ genug ist, die Drehbücher auch wirklich griffig zu formulieren, die dann letzten Endes die Kommunikation definieren sollen.
Also in der Tat glaube ich, dass die Wissenschaft, gerade jetzt die Scientist for Future, da schon wirklich sehr sehr gut unterwegs waren und dass die uns schon Bilder gezeigt haben,
die eigentlich uns genug aufrütteln müssten.
Warum das dann doch nicht passiert, hat wie gesagt meines Erachtens einfach damit zu tun, das es für uns immer noch zu weit ist und wir nicht das Gefühl haben, dass es uns wirklich betrifft.
Das ist ja eben genau der Punkt.
Wenn jetzt diese ganzen Lockerungen, solange bin ich dafür, also nicht ich, sondern ich als Mensch bin ich dafür, wie in meinem Umfeld nichts passiert ist.
Sobald in meinem Umfeld was passiert, werde ich meine Meinung ändern.
Das ist, glaube ich, recht menschlich und insofern dieses Dranbleiben, klar darüber nachdenken, wie kann man Dinge vielleicht nochmal anders darstellen.
Das würde ich jetzt aber nicht alleine nur als wissenschaftliche Aufgabe, sondern in der Tat als gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe sehen.
Da gibt es ja auch andere Akteurinnen und Akteure und da brauchen wir, glaube ich, auch so einen Zusammenschluss, dass eben die Wissenschaft, dass NGOs, dass im Prinzip auch diejenigen,
die in diesem Themenfeld aktiv sind, da auch gemeinsam Lösungen entwickeln.
Allein wird das die Wissenschaft nicht schaffen, aber ich glaube, dass sie da unglaublich wichtige Impulse in den letzten Jahren schon gegeben hat und da ein wichtiger Player geworden ist,
der auch wahrgenommen wird, der auch ernst genommen wird, der auch in den Medien auftritt.
Ich glaube, da muss man so weitermachen und darf sich nicht entmutigen lassen.
Das sind halt Themen, die offenbar lange oder länger brauchen, die Debatte haben wir ja auch schon länger und werden wahrscheinlich nicht von einem Tag auf den anderen die Einstellungen verändern,
aber ich glaube schon, dass sich in den letzten Jahren auch, natürlich gerade auch durch die jungen Menschen, die auf die Straße gegangen sind, und die eigentlich auch erst den Anstoß gegeben haben,
dass sich dadurch schon einiges verändert hat in den Köpfen.
Weil denen klarer ist, was sie zu verlieren haben.
Das ist in der Tat vermutlich auch genau der Punkt.
Wenn ich die Kommunikation …
Also Kommunikation auf Zielgruppen hin zu orientieren heißt natürlich auch, dass die Zielgruppen merken, dass sie was damit zu tun haben und das ist leider den jungen Menschen klarer,
wobei ich glaube, auch schon inzwischen die älteren, die Familie haben, die Kinder haben, die Enkelkinder haben, das schon auch so sehen.
Die Frage der eigenen Verhaltensänderung, das ist wirklich ein schwieriges Thema, inwiefern ich nicht nur sage, ja ich finde das ja alles gut und richtig, aber ich selber steige trotzdem noch in den Flieger,
was ich übrigens nicht mehr tue, aber inwiefern man da wirklich sich das eigene Verhalten anpasst und verändert, da braucht es wahrscheinlich irgendwie doch noch mehr Kreativität und Fantasie, wie Sie schon gesagt hatten.
Ob da ein Hollywoodstreifen reicht, mal gucken, weiß ich nicht.
Gut, ich denke, damit sind wir so ein bisschen an der gesteckten Ziele hier für dieses Gespräch geraten.
Gibt es noch etwas, was Sie uns zusätzlich mitgeben wollen, was wir jetzt so noch vielleicht nicht direkt angesprochen haben?
Naja ich glaube, wir sind da durch das Thema ganz gut durchgekommen.
Ich glaube, was ich vielleicht noch an der Stelle einfach betonen möchte, ist, dass Kommunikation auch einfach unglaublich viel Spaß macht und dass man keine Angst davor haben muss,
auch wenn es manchmal Reaktionen gibt, die einem nicht gefallen.
Insofern sich darauf einzulassen, auch mal andere Menschen zu erreichen als die, mit denen man sonst so zu tun hatte, kann wirklich auch ein sehr befriedigendes Gefühl sein.
Und das auszuprobieren und vielleicht auch mal zu erleben, dass man damit auch mal vielleicht scheitert oder die eigenen Ansprüche nicht ganz erfüllt, ich glaube, das ist es trotzdem wert.
Und ich sehe da ein ganz großes Potenzial.
Übrigens wir hatten gerade über die jungen Menschen gesprochen, die auf die Straße gehen und gegen den Klimawandel demonstrieren, da sehe ich ein ganz großes Potenzial eben auch bei den Nachwuchswissenschaftlerinnen,
die wir haben, die eben auch mit neuen Medien, mit anderen Medien groß geworden sind, die eine größere Offenheit vielleicht auch haben, die rechtzeitig ins Boot zu holen.
Und da ist es dann allerdings wichtig, aber das will ich jetzt nur noch zum Ende sagen, dass wir da keine politische Diskussion damit jetzt aufmachen, da ist es natürlich auch wichtig,
dass die in irgendeiner Form merken, dass es ihnen zumindest nicht schadet, im besten Fall auch für ihre wissenschaftlichen Karrieren was nutzt.
Ja, ich denke, man ist jetzt auch ein bisschen weiter aufgestiegen in der Superhelden-Kategorie, wo man so potenziell als Weltenretter wahrgenommen werden kann.
Das hat mancher ja schon verinnerlicht.
Genau.
Da sind auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge Stellen zu besetzen in diesem Segment.
Ja.
Ja, Frau Molthagen-Schnöring, vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Vielen Dank, dass ich hier mit Ihnen mich austauschen durfte.
Ja.
Und auch vielen Dank an alle Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer von Forschergeist.
Das war es für diese Ausgabe.
Wir hören uns hier sicherlich bald wieder.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.